[Music]
welcome all right and we are live more
Cognito here Lords of gaming dotnet iron
Lord podcast and we have ghost runner
here but what is fine this fine
gentleman here in the realm today what's
your name what's your role with this
game hello everyone my name is Rebecca
and I am a king director of ghost runner
Rose Rana now go for it definitely was
one of the games that caught my eye here
in the realm so I have to ask you right
what is the premise of goes for a tell
the people what is this game about so
this game is about being a cybernetic
ninja whoa no cognate by name is based
off ninja boy this is perfect so so yes
so everything is set in that dream
post-apocalyptic cyberpunk world the low
volume okay let's go yeah so it's kind
of precise you have to time your attacks
you have time your jumps okay and this
is like the core mechanic of our game we
are inspired by title and also by our
previous title and low Titan forward
that wall running yeah they were running
this is like mixing up this several
mechanics like the movement mechanics
who are running with the slow motion and
also this called one sweet one cue gives
us some kind of unique uniqueness in
this game something fresh yeah
absolutely I want to expound upon the
one hit one kill aspect
now when you say that this applies to
both the antagonist and the enemies Wow
so you have to be careful yourself where
you get out you'll be out of it
yeah but you can feel powerful if you
like killing spree let's say you kill
three or five enemies in a row without
being touched you feel very powerful
okay now we if you change kind of those
type of attacks together are their
combos or their bonuses what's the move
sets that our character has yes so the
the biggest change for the player is to
reach the enemy not the execution of the
of him but to reach them in the right
way okay so you have several abilities
you can jump you can - you can use light
to avoid bullets you can use that slow
motion running and later during the
progression of the game you can also
have some special abilities we are not
spoiling it for now although there will
be some ultimate abilities but also you
can extend your basic kind of example
okay so we really go in depth it's a
will are we gonna see some sort of a
skill tree in intercession with that
being that you talk about a lot of a
bill you talk about slowing time all
these different things it won't be the
just skill tree it will be something
like you can combine let's say some some
shapes okay and get some manipulation of
things oh that's that's even more
creative okay cool so the world you know
one hit one kill um now how are we
looking at cs4 our stages are very fast
paced very you know you have to use your
bills you have to use your timing I love
it
my question now is do we have boss
fights so to speak at the end of stages
like well as we progress up how does
that mechanic work yeah so there will be
several boss fights and
it's like we are not showing it right
now but we have a bride yes for them
it's like working progress
work-in-progress
don't doubt how far we in development
right now this is very early with
pre-alpha where where are we in
development yeah we can we can call it a
pre-alpha it's like we are almost done
with the content for in terms of level
design so yeah it takes us a couple of
months now in the first what game looks
absolutely fantastic
engine-wise what are you guys using so
this is under engine for the big thing
was for us that we moved from unity to
engine and why sauce yeah we are also
using our TX technology in this game so
it can really cool yes very much so
now as far as platforms what are we
looking at for those for like where are
we thinking right now we started
initially PC or we going to console or
what are we looking at yeah PC of course
and we also targeting ps4 and Xbox one
maybe the next generation consoles that
proceed possibly in 2020 okay cuz I mean
this would look amazing 4k 60 frames per
second I'm just saying me personally so
what else could you tell the gamers Oh
accident interested in this game you
know what's that what are some of the
other features they can look out for for
this game that we could get people
excited - what - picks up so here in
this demo we have just one type of the
enemy and we
have over 10 types of the enemies which
when we mix them with each other of
there will be many challenges for that
there will be some for example so enemy
which makes you stop you have to stand
re his attack ok to get to make
now let me ask you about the sword
itself because I'm getting uh overwatch
Eng vibes so my question is um will he
be locked into this weapon specifically
does he get all the weapons or do you
upgrade this particular weapon yeah so
this sword is like a main weapon of the
character and it can be enhanced during
the progression so we'll be mostly using
this sword
we have several ideas for how do you
plan on not having like a pulse or
anything like that for them to to kind
of you know get through the levels
themselves yes yes we have some kind of
cyber space which will be the place
where the players can breathe take a
breath and they can you know slow down a
little bit they can figure out some
puzzles and that will be the space where
we were we are providing the story to
the player thoughts of having new like
the use of the cybernetics for the ninja
themselves because like I've watched
those when you're like unlocking certain
portions is there something like that
that you guys are gonna be adding
they're kind of like guys puzzles
cybernetic option yeah there will be
some kind of hacking and it's for resorb
where we at right now as far as
resolution frame rate
what's our initial targets you know
right now assuming they're because
thought first would be like to have
60fps the target and now again I know
it's the levels are oh I was seeing
right now pretty wide open open spaces
like that
you know is that the general theme of
going like that you want this type of
open space or they're gonna be levels
maybe that they might not be as much
there may be more Titan it
very cool it's also enhancing our
movement mechanics oh yeah so there are
many open spaces like you can take a
several paths yeah but there will be
also some more straightforward now last
question now I mean you actually took
two more questions
one in reference to obviously hits I
could tell where this game gets you get
more advanced it gets harder yes so that
one hit one kill is very real now what
about you what about the pushback so
these games are so hard are you gonna do
anything - so baby accommodate those
those type of players or that's just the
philosophy of goes for that you gotta
get better we dark souls in this thing
yeah it's like we want this game to be
for a hardcore nice you know there will
be this progression system which can
help you it won't be like you can use it
but it's not a must
oh is that I'm a sort optional easy boys
easy move for the easy Bo Peep last
question we're gonna say it reference to
story beats right you'll get cool
character cool world yeah I decide upon
you get the cybernetics you got ninjas
you got titanfall movement a lot of
things going on now how we gonna
approach story dirt for this game are we
doing cinematics how what is the way
we're gonna convey the story to the
gamer so mostly we are the player is is
in the constant connection with the AI
of the building he's like a narrator
leading okay we will connect to several
other other people okay big he's got a
lot of ideas good at week a week now are
you gonna be playing on I having like
multiple people like if you have like a
two-player co-op
you have like another person like you
have play a strictly singular
single-player for now it's just single
player okay let's say ghost and we are
focusing on single player of course it
would be great someday I do I know it's
early as far as like um legit I mean far
as like levels like you know any idea
how long as far as gameplay length
you're looking at because I get I don't
you guys got a lot of crazy ideas you
could be creative or is this something
that you're going for more you know
linear maybe 10 and 12 level kind of
experience yeah so time should be over
five hours of course it depends on the
players but five hours five hours maybe
seven this is what we estimate right now
looking good man ghosts running you
heard it here first
in the realm looking absolutely
fantastic coming to PC and platform
recollect Xbox ps4 and Xbox one and
possibly the next-generation consoles as
well and we're definitely looking for
this is definitely on the iron Lords
list an absolute pleasure to have you in
the realm this is absolutely fantastic
man ghostwriter
[Music]
you
[Music]